well it seems to become the tradition
for me to open these conferences by
talking about my kind of evolving view
of the data universe and its each year
there are new and different things that
happen for me these are very exciting
times because there's a technology stack
that we basically been building for
close to 30 years that is really coming
together beautifully and many things
that have we've been working towards for
decades now a sort of just finally
coming to fruition it's kind of a
mixture of things we've done and things
that have happened in the world that
make this possible obviously the
technology we've built has been widely
used in research and development for
many years I mean you know ninety
percent of universities in the US now
have site licenses for our technology
and it's used throughout sort of the
research and development world I think
the thing that is particularly exciting
now is that we've really cracked how to
put all of the stuff that we've built
into production in very kind of
industrial environments so to speak and
I think the what's to me exciting about
this is it really changes the sort of
the character and economics of what's
possible with sophisticated computation
and it's it seems like this is the year
when this is all finally happening it's
a mixture of lots of engineering that
we've done lots of building up of our
technology stack lots of things that
happen in the world in general you kind
of tell that something something
interesting is happening because they're
all sorts of Silicon Valley startups
that are starting to notice that gosh
you can use our technology stack to do
all kinds of things that never been
possible before that's usually a leading
indicator of other things going on I
mean we've actually been holding back a
bit on really announcing promoting
everything that we have because we've
been doing lots of difficult engineering
to really consumer eyes being able to
scale up the kinds of capabilities that
we have and especially in things related
to the cloud and it's almost done I I
think every every within months I think
we will finally be at the point where we
feel completely confident that we built
something that is scalable all the way I
mean we've done a number of tests you
may have no
just during this year a few things I'll
probably talk about them a bit later
kind of interesting websites that have
shown up that a couple of them that got
to a million users in their first day
part of the reason we did those was part
was because we thought they were
interesting websites but part was
because we were testing the scaling of
our infrastructure to make sure that it
will actually work up to those kinds of
scales and the good news is it does
actually work so the thing that has been
sort of a theme of everything we've
we've tried to do is sort of automate
everything kind of automate as much as
possible in the way that computation
gets done and now the sort of the new
thing is also automating the deployment
of of computation making kind of the
machine do as much as possible and the
humans just have to sort of define the
goals and then let the Machine figure
out how to achieve those well let's see
if we can go here yes good so kind of
the the 11 mode of that is the whole
wolframalpha experience where the where
the goal has been to kind of have a zero
learning environment where you can just
ask questions in natural language and
werewolf malvel will figure out sort of
what are some things that you might find
interesting to sort of generate an
automated report that shows you not just
the specific answer to your question but
also related things that it thinks you
might find interesting and this kind of
zillow learning approach to being able
to ask questions and compute
knowledge-based results has been has
been very successful it's it's used in
lots of places sort of consumer places
like Siri and so on it's also used every
day by many millions of people directly
on the web and it's become sort of a
dominant thing in how students for
example find information in areas like
math and science and so on so but but
the things that we're really sort of
alpha is kind of the the zero learning
kind of approach to to dealing with a
very wide range of of knowledge when
we've covered a lot of different areas
that we've been trying to make use of
data and knowledge and set it up so that
any question which can in principle be
answered on the basis of of systematic
knowledge that exists in the world we
can automatically answer when the
question is is given to us in natural
language but the thing that has sort of
the the centerpiece of the technology
stack that we've been building for such
a long time and going forward is what we
call the Wolfram language and the
Wolfram language is sort of a a merger
of the technology that's emerged from
Mathematica system and Wolf malva and
lots of new things and then also now
feeding back into mathematica or more
from alpha and so on but sort of the
centerpiece of all of this is well from
language and kind of the idea of often
language is it's a it's a
knowledge-based language it's a language
where we try and build in as much
knowledge about computation and about
the world as possible kind of the the
traditional approach to computer
languages is tended to be have a rather
small language and then perhaps people
build libraries to do specific things on
top of that small language what we've
done with the Wolfram language now over
the course of nearly 30 is is to is to
build something where we try and put as
much knowledge in right into the
language as possible so it's a very big
language as opposed to being a small
language it's a big language with you
know 5,000 sort of built-in primitives
and so on and that though the goal is to
have a coherently designed system that
covers a very broad area of capability
well so i think the we we've used the
Wolfram language to do many things for
example if an alpha is written in the
welcome language is about 15 million
lines of open language code at this
point the wolfman language kind of spans
very small
code very large code it's also been the
place where we've taken a lot of data
that we've accumulated for example of an
alpha in making data sort of accessible
in more mouthful we've have to get to a
quite a high bar of making the data
computable in the sense that if there's
a question that kind of principle be
answered on the basis of that data we
should make it sort of automatic to be
able to answer that question the bar is
still higher when we're integrating that
kind of data into our sort of systematic
Wolfram language environment and so one
of the things that we've been doing is
taking a lot of data including some from
from people here and getting it to the
point where it's it's computable to the
level that it can be used systematically
in the orphan language well so there are
lots and lots of things that can be
built with the wolfman language and
we're starting to see all sorts of
things in the world built with it but
maybe I should start off and just sort
of show you a few things that but we can
do and both sort of traditional things
that won't be able to see for years and
also of course lots of new stuff because
that's that's the fun of running a
software companies you get to show all
the all the new stuff that doesn't
really exist yet um which means it
probably won't work properly but we'll
see what happens so let's say okay so
things are alive it's working um let's
let's let's see what we can do too I'll
just do some sort of live live coding
kinds of things to try and give some
kind of feeling for what it's like to do
things in the Wolfram language so you
know like for example we might have some
function you know Roman numeral ok so
there's we get some Roman numeral let's
say we make a table of Roman numerals
from let's say I don't know how to up to
100 let's say okay so there's a bunch of
Roman numerals let's say we want to
let's do some sort of really elementary
data science let's say we make a list
line plot of string length of let's
let's just take this and use that um and
say like this okay so there's the
there's the
sort of the efficiency or inefficiency
of Roman numerals as a let's go up to
200 or something kind of interesting
pattern and we could for example say
let's use a different plot theme here
let's go and you know it's do a a
marketing oriented plot theme here um
okay that's some so that's so it gives
us some kind of visualization of our you
know Roman numerals as a function of
size or for example we could say let's
take come let's take something like this
and let's say let's make a histogram of
those lengths okay there we go maybe
we're let's do it up to a thousand here
um okay that's kind of interesting
surprising the source for a potential
Gaussian I don't know know it now I'm
really curious whether whether I'm now I
got to find out we've got Chum oh they
have a nice function here so it does
okay oh it says it's a binomial
distribution okay with with parameter
point for so that was that was again
it's a pretty automated thing we're
doing here we've just got some data and
we're now just saying find distribution
and it's looking in the sort of space of
all possible kind of name distributions
to try and find the one that that fits
best in this case i don't know let's try
doing something like let's try something
slightly different here let's take it
let's take our Roman numerals let's take
a few few fewer Roman numerals and let's
say how about we do this let's say let's
make a graph let's make a
nearest-neighbor graph where we're using
I guess some kind of edit distance to
know the the the distance between sort
of neighboring things okay so here we've
got a graph that shows kind of the the
how the Roman numerals what what Roman
numeral was nearest in some edit
distance to what other Roman numeral so
we can make all kinds of graphs I don't
know we can pick up this graph and we
could make come let's say we make a
community graph plot out of that graph
so we can just use this graph but that
graph into that function and now we're
getting my not quite know what this
means but but we're getting them sort of
the clumps of
roman numeral ism on quite sure what
that is but have to take a little bit
more about it um so okay so this is this
is some so that was some sort of
something fun let's try something
different let's let's pick up an image
for example here see kids do again okay
there you go there's an image so now we
could for example say let's try making
them let's try just saying something
like um partition that image so let's
take take the image here and let's
partition it into little things of size
20 or something so now we've got we've
got that image we could go ahead and we
could say you know sort the rows here
maybe we could assemble that image into
something I'm it's kind of weird we
could if we wanted to we could um that's
let's well let's take this and let's say
for example let's let's just do a
different kind of analysis let's say we
make a a 3d chromaticity plot which is
going to give us the the color levels in
that image okay so there we go and now
maybe what we can do is we can say let's
make a dynamic if there's going to work
let's see let's make a dynamic
chromaticity plot of the current image
so what we're going to that that's going
to be showing the the color levels um
ends if this works ok and now probably
if I start waving at it not so obvious
what it's doing but that that's giving
me now the sort of the real-time display
of the chromaticity of that image maybe
I can maybe I can pair that I could do
something simpler let's just say I'm and
we can do some very standard thing like
that's just just to prove it's doing
something it's sensible have a go so now
it's edgy detecting me in real time so
so again we can do all sorts of things
with all sorts of different kinds of
data in the Wolfen language let's let's
pick up some other let's try and getting
some data let's just try pulling in
something from the outside world let's
say we pull in the
loads up let's see come on I hope the
correction network if we're not
connected network it's going to be bad
um that's really odd I think we're going
to not with otherwise I wouldn't have
been able to reach various websites here
okay that's not what I expected at all
um anybody got in there anybody from our
team got any ideas what's going on no
all right let's try something here let's
do some real time debugging let's try
that um first of all it shouldn't need
to be updating and second rule it should
if it is updating it should be updating
quickly well that's a shame I thought I
was going to be able to do some nice
some nice thing pulling in data from up
here right as so we can get sure
although this is a bad sign very bad
sign okay well alright we will we'll be
able to do something here alright let's
try let's try this okay so let's let's
get some like an English dictionary and
let's say how about we do this let's
let's take them take the first letter
from a hundred thousand words in an
English dictionary and then let's say
something like come let's make let's
make a word cloud out of those so this
should be okay so this is showing us a
word cloud of what the most popular
first letters are in an English
dictionary he could maybe do the same
thing I don't know let's do the same we
could we could do that for let's say we
do it for a Russian dictionary I'm
instead then we'll get a bunch of a
bunch of other letters here you do the
same kind of thing again unless this is
not accessing the network which it
probably needs to do for this
um humph let's try something here we
need to see things are even vaguely
alive although the network is just now
that's what you hmm it's odd very odd um
how about well okay we'll keep going
hope for the best I'm okay so one of the
things sort of interesting about what
languages it's kind of mixing things
that are happening locally with things
that are happening in the cloud or being
retrieved from the cloud and normally
it's all perfectly seamless and you
wouldn't know that there was a that
there were two different places where
computation was happening except when
you can't reach one of them so okay so
another big thing about walking
languages is the knowledge that it has
of sort of real-world data so for
instance seeming this is going to work
we can um we could type in something
like Washington DC okay there we go did
that did work to some reason um so so
what what happens is we're using in this
case natural language to kind of specify
all these different kinds of entities in
the world and now we have this thing
that is is an object that we can
manipulate in our language just like any
other kind of thing just like an image
just like a graph and just like a string
or something but now it's a real world
entity and there are tens of millions of
these real world entities that the
system knows about so for example I
could say I know something like them
let's say US states ok so there's US
states and now let's get a list of those
entities um and okay there's a list of
u.s. states and now for example let's
say I could say let's try doing
something like an to do list of that
from a flag so this is going to
hopefully give us the that's interesting
I didn't mean entity list i meant turned
red which is good because that's some
wrong okay so let's say I want to get
them I'm going to ask about the flags of
all the US states okay so they're a
bunch of state flags and now I could for
example ask for i don't know i could say
how about to do this let's say I could I
could say something like show me the
dominant colors of all those state flags
or I could go and say let's take them
okay so there's the dominant colors from
those flags so now for example I could
do something I don't know let's say I
could take them I could create a
function that represents that computes
what's nearest to a given thing so for
example here I have this nearest
function and I could say take that
nearest function and take a US flag and
tell me these states let's say the let's
say the five state flags that are
nearest according in some measure of
nearness that I don't think any of them
are particularly close to the US flag
those are the ones that it thinks by
some measure of visual similarity it's
really odd that it thinks that one is
but that term the things are near to the
US flag in some in some and some such
measure so let's try how about we try
something different let's try and again
we're making but that's just oh yeah
it's kind of kind of fun to see if we if
we did something like let's do this
let's take this state flags and let's
find the populations of all the states
so let's say was that I should have
given names to these things but I didn't
okay first online eight so let's say I
asked for those and I say what's the
population of each of those and sort of
give me the populations of all the
states and I say take that and the
actual state flags there we go 19 um and
let's make an image collage of those
state flags where the waiting in the
image collage is as proportional
populations are that's showing that the
state flags of the US some and a size
waited by the population it's kind of
cool that we can do this in
in sort of one or two lines of code and
so on them with data that's all built
into the system and okay i'll actually
learn some state flags from this um
there we could certainly do that um well
let's see what will we do we've got our
dominant colors here um how would we do
this we would have to say I think this
requires a little bit too much thought
we could plot the dominant color as a
function of yeah we could do a scatter
plot of the dominant color as a function
of population let's let's not do that
because we will end up getting I will
have a very bad habit of doing these
experiments doing deeper and deeper
experiments live let's let's um let's
try it okay how about um let's take take
our US states for example and let's just
do let's do something different here
let's say they take the US states and
let's say how about we do the Capitals
so again we're going to use some this
will now use natural language to give us
some to let us do the queries so there's
a bunch of results of the Capitals now
let's go ahead and get some let's go
ahead and find out what the geo
positions of all those capitals is and
then what we're going to do is take
those geo positions and let's say we can
say find a shortest tour you know solve
the Traveling Salesman problem okay wake
up computer are you doing here come on
wyd it's something as odd is going on
because some things that should be super
fast are taking forever probably yes so
you never know what happens um that's
the oh dear and some I'll tell you what
let's try let's just try saying this
let's just try doing them let's try
if this works okay well there we've got
a bunch of so those are the geo
positions of the state capitals now we
can say find shortest tour of those so
this will now give us the the ordering
so it says the 16,000 miles is the
length of the Torah and now let's take
that second part of that and let's apply
it to 117 this so this should give us
that sequence of positions for state
capitals and now let's say let's make a
geo list plot of that with them joined
true so we want to join them all up and
now what we should have here this works
is a come on this should give us a nice
picture something very odd is happening
here okay let me just see what the
things are working at all let's say see
if it knows where we are okay so there's
the geo position but it thinks this
computer is at so let's say we make come
graphics let's say of a geo disk around
here with radius server I don't know
five miles or something so this works
aha thinks we're in the middle of
nowhere okay and things were in Kansas
okay well we have to tell it we're not
in Kansas anymore um and that's also
very odd okay um okay yeah but that's
the thousand-mile um diameter version of
that okay so let's try let's just try
this one more time here I think it would
be cool to see this oh there we go okay
it work now um so that's that's now that
solve the Traveling Salesman problem for
a tour between all US Capitol the US
state capitals so again I think that's
that's it's pretty nice that we have
we have stated the art algorithms for
solving the Traveling Salesman problem
and it's all kind of you know freely
accessible because you just take find
shortest tour and it figures out the
right way to solve the Traveling
Salesman problem for that number of
items and so on in this case on the
surface of the earth so it understands
you know you can see that line is
slightly curved there is in this
projection that's what that's what's
happening and so on so it's it's just
easy to figure out lots of stuff um I
don't know you can it's it's nice to
explore different kinds of data so for
instance let's say we've got them
something like them see if I can do this
something like geo elevation data for
the earth so here I'm just going to let
me just get sort of the the complete geo
elevation data for some grid on the
earth and now I could say for example
make a histogram of of all of those
values from geo elevation so this tells
us for four sort of everywhere on the
earth this is the histogram of what the
the height of the of the of the surface
is so it's kind of interesting actually
I made this plot a couple of months ago
for the first time and I was sort of
surprised there's there's lots of land
that's right near sea level and then
there's this weird peek down that tongue
I guess this is in feet so it like
15,000 feet below below the below sea
level so I thought that was that was
sort of interesting but it's kind of
it's kind of nice that you can just take
we have all the street validation data
we have actually very detailed geo
elevation data for the earth and you can
just pick it all up and take that plot
and find something interesting about it
so we've been we've been steadily
accumulating Gator on lots of kinds of
things I don't know if we'd say
something like how about we do this
let's take a random let's just go for a
particular domain let's say I'm a random
entity let's say rat 30 random movies
okay and now we could say something like
come get some get for example images
associated with 30 random movies okay we
didn't we weren't lucky that time let's
try it again let's try another 30 um
that's
am i doing um okay we have a we have of
all possible movies we have posters for
the vast majority of internal I would
okay okay we had okay that wasn't very
exciting only a few movie posters there
but in any case we could if I if I said
give me give me a bunch of random random
movies let's get a hundred random movies
let's get some let's get try and get
posters for them I could have tried to
do in analysis of I don't know let's say
how the dominant colors of these posters
have changed over the course of time
that's safely if we delete the missing
ones here I don't know what those those
those missing ones maybe from very small
budget movies that that aren't too
exciting but we could you know we kid
again we can go and do our dominant
colors thing here or we could go and
compute a sort of images as a function
of time and so on lots lots of kinds of
things we can do we could go ahead and
we could say or no we could say
something we could use some natural
language here we could say movies by
let's say directed by Steven Spielberg
here and hopefully will understand that
natural language now let's get a list of
those entities um and you should get a
list of entities and we can then get
posters for those and go on and compute
all kinds of things um so we as I say
we've been collecting data on on sort of
every possible thing the bar for having
this data be computable is very high
when you can actually do things directly
in the Wolfram language with it an
example something we've recently worked
on is some anatomical data so for
example if i say let's say skull here
and let's say we have about 80,000
objects in the human body so for example
if i say skull and i want 3d graphics
see if this works i should be able to
get a high-resolution 3d graphics with
that actually the whole whole kind of
okay there we go um and there it is in
in proper 3d or if I let let's take it
let's take something a little bit
mahler let's take a female for example
and actually what I probably want to say
come on wake up computer let's let's
just say left femur for example um and
then let's say something like let's get
the mesh region of the left femur and so
that will now give me a something where
I could actually start computing I could
do finite element analysis on this thing
or whatever I want to do or I could just
say let's just do something simple let's
just say what's the area of that and
that will give me the area and I think
square millimeters here um so there's a
there's a the sort of a an X oral
process that we've been going through
trying to trying to add data on
everything and we've developed a lot of
I think quite interesting expertise over
the last decade instead of how to curate
data and make it computable it's a hard
business and it requires one of the
things that's kind of difficult about it
is it requires judgment calls that kind
of every turn it's not something where
you just you know shovel the data into a
computer and expected to do everything
for you it's something that actually
requires human experts to be injected
into the process and to really make
something that's that's useful and I'm
working and we've been as I said we've
been adding all kinds of areas an area
we recently have added a lot of stuff
for is some cars show you an example of
that let's say something like an alpha
say let's say compact cars with the
largest say ground clearance see what it
does so hopefully among connect
I was wrong this network argh wake up
connect okay so that I can figure that
out um something is very amiss here with
how this is connected network come on
it's frustrating when I think the actual
come on okay well anyway um this is what
I get for doing live then let's sulit
let's see what anything looks here um
Dalek generic Wi-Fi so I know what's
happening well anyway it would be nice
if we go okay for some reason now it
works okay so this is giving us I have
no idea if this is correct but I'm sure
it is this is giving us 4 2015 cars the
EPA classified as compact passenger cars
this is giving us some ranking and I'm
sure if we if we press one of these will
see a lot more detail about about that
particular kind of car and there's just
one domain this how it happens to be a
quite complicated domain because there
are lots of kind of variations and the
ontology is pretty elaborate but we can
get some his some here's some data on
I'm placing his some data on fuel
economy and so on lots of kinds of
things that we can compute about cars
okay there's the wikipedia page hits
history for that particular kind of car
which tells us something about sort of
the level of interest and public
visibility that it's had as a function
of time so anyway we've been we've been
doing over the course of the last many
years we've been adding more and more
built-in data to the public Wolfram
Alpha that
that people use every day another thing
that's been happening is we've been
building a whole bunch of custom Wharf
malphas for large organizations and
that's been a very interesting and
successful business and lots of custom
wolf malphas have been built that have
curated data from within organizations
and actually this year will see the
first few of those that will happen to
be also getting exposed to the outside
world for various kinds of consumer
purposes so that will be that will be an
interesting thing making use of our
natural language understanding stack and
mixing typically curated data from
within an organization with kind of
public curated data that exists within
the wolfman alpha knowledge base so any
case there's that there's a lot of data
that is built into or from alpha one of
the things that we've also been
interested in is dealing with sort of
the the flow of additional data in real
time from devices and so on obviously we
have lots of real-time feeds that tell
us about earthquakes and market prices
and and weather and all kinds of other
things but the question is can we easily
take some connected device that's been
produced and and flow data from that
into our into our cloud and into our
technology stack and one of the things
we've been interested in we've been sort
of curate and we curated all kinds of
things we've been curating kinds of
connected devices his website where we
have a data on a couple of thousand
kinds of connected devices that measure
all sorts of different kinds of things
and you can can say what kinds of things
they measure their measure all sorts of
things a typical interaction with
companies that make these kinds of
devices is they built some great device
they say we've got the sensor it
measures really well say what are you
actually going to do with the data from
the center so well well we're going to
you know hire a bunch of programmers and
build some cloud back-end to feed data
from our sensor into and so our one of
our goals has been to have them not try
to do that because it's really hard and
there's no point in everybody doing it
for themselves and so we've been trying
to build a sort of general cloud back
and for connected devices and sensor
data and so on and it that's been rather
successful and a whole bunch of
companies are starting to use us to
provide the the sort of cloud back-end
for data that comes from sensors so let
me let me show you what happens I should
show you the so the thing we built as we
call it well from data drop and the idea
is that it's a place where you can just
drop data somehow from things for
through an API you can tweet to it you
can use an Arduino you can use various
other kinds of devices one recent thing
I wonder whether it's listed here it's
being used able to use if if this then
that you can you can use all sorts of
different methods to get your data from
a connected device into the cloud once
it comes into the cloud it will come in
as a data bin so for example I could go
and look at what data bins do i
currently have okay so there's a bunch
of sensors that I have sitting on my
desk let's say I get them I take that
the data that has been accumulated from
from the little board of censors that I
have sitting on my desk at home and this
should give me and see if this works
here this should show me the data that's
come from from those from those sensors
okay there we go so here's some data
humidity light pressure temperature okay
let's take this let's get a time series
of that data and let's talk thing again
okay so now let's take the for example
the pressure time series here and now
for example I can do the date list plot
thing on that again and I'll get some
that's pressure as a function of time
for the sensor on my desk kind of fun to
take a look let's take a look for a line
44 let's say let's just get let's find
out what the first date there was okay
let's get the last date in that time
series and now let me go ahead and say
air pressure data for Concord
Massachusetts which is where I live and
let's say that for from
first date 946 to the last 8 9 40 47 and
let's try to retrieve from public data
the the air pressure between those two
dates and that saves since then say it's
ready with a date list plot here
hopefully come on wake up um hopefully
this will this will be able to get um
get their pressure data it's kind of
weird actually all these oscillations
that you see here I wonder what that's
due to maybe that's daily no I'm sure
I'm okay we should be able to get should
be able to find out what's happening oh
did I do um okay with luck this will go
and give us some air pressure as a
function of time um one of the things
that we're working on so the data drop
is this place where you can just take
take data from some device for example
or from some process that's going on
whether it's you know people filling out
a survey or lots of other kinds of
things and just throw this data into a
data drop each data drop gets some
unique ID and that we can then that that
term is then accessible either from the
web or from inside the Wolfram language
or from other languages and you can then
go and do computations with them with
the data from that day to drop ah there
we go we finally got it okay so this is
so this is now that was the the public
data for that that's the that's the time
series for so they look at should rather
similar words let's take let's take a
look here let's say I'm okay so this is
that's comparing the that's comparing
the data from from my desk with the data
from local weather station and probably
there's probably an overall difference
because the the altitude of my house is
a little different from the altitude of
the of the nearest nearest weather
station but it gives you some idea of
how one can get data from a little
real-time device and compare it with
public data and so
on so any case that the data drop is
this way of getting sort of feeds of
data from little devices another thing
that we have been building is what we
call our data repository which is
intended to be more a place for people
to put large blobs of data and the idea
is to have an easy way to get access to
those large blobs of data from the
orphan language and to set it up as a
place where for example people who are
doing research can you know publish
their data which is something that
everybody's sort of wanted to see happen
but it's been a thing that's been hard
to achieve in a way web the data is
actually usable one of the really
important things about data in our kind
of ecosystem is that it's sort of
immediately computable and meaningful we
have this thing we call wdf for from
data framework which is kind of an
exposure of the ontology that we built
on the sort of algorithmic ontology that
we've built for full from alpha to allow
people to take their data and put it in
this kind of standardized computable
form so for instance even at a very
simple level you know data comes with
you know quantities come with different
kinds of units okay there are 10,000
different kinds of units that are in use
all of which we have sort of carefully
curated for from alpha and all of which
are now sort of immediately accessible
within wdf so let's see the maybe one
example let me try one one example of
thumb of what you can do with that if I
had this yes I do um okay so here's an
example here's a recent example of using
sort of our sort of ontology on food and
this is slightly more elaborate example
let me just make it bigger so this is
just looking at different kinds of foods
and you can say I don't know there's a
egg whole fried cooked food item and his
you know things things that we know
about it like its nutrition label and
all sorts of other detailed quantities
of amounts of various different kinds of
things here's an example where we're
looking at some kind of implicitly
defined
what we say it's a food type entity its
approximate shape of the sphere it's
typical outside color is red now let's
get an image of it and so now we're
getting red spherical kinds of foods and
being able to do this kind of thing
within a sort of algorithmic ontology i
think is as an interesting and important
thing well okay so that's something
that's made possible by this wdf
mechanism the other thing to understand
is that because we've also got our
natural language understanding stack we
can take things that come from sort of
unwashed spreadsheets and so on and
understand that yes this column is a
place name this column is a is a date
and so on and the way that works
internally we have this whole mechanism
of what we call interpreters so for
example there are hundreds of different
kinds of these if I say you know
something like the Eiffel Tower here and
I say interpret that as a location this
some this will now give me the geo
position of the Eiffel Tower okay so
let's some let's take a look at some
other kinds of things so one question is
when you when you get data into our
language what are some convenient ways
to kind of handle that data so one thing
that we've recently introduced is
something which is kind of our version
of a mixture of kind of SQL and no SQL
database technology kind of made into
something more unified and modern by the
fact that our language is a symbolic
language I mean I should have mentioned
that the the fact that it's possible to
have a thing in the language which is an
image or a graph or a representation of
Washington DC or a movie or something
like that is made possible by the fact
that this is a symbolic language so you
can so any one of these kinds of things
if I say if I say something like this
this is just a object that the system
can recognize can deal with as a
symbolic thing it doesn't have to have a
value of 17 or something it's just a
symbolic object that doesn't miss
dealing with so here I've got some here
I had something where I'm
I'm looking at some I'm asking I'm
saying get me this is just an example
data set that's kind of a mixture of
something kind of tabular and something
hierarchical I could go ahead and I
could say you know planets some all come
a radius for example and that will give
me the radio planets I could say you
know make me a bar chart of this I could
say something like um let's say I want
some planets and I want all planets and
I want the moons of the planets and then
I want to take the total mass of all the
moons of each planet so this is now
going to take me in this in this kind of
data set this is now going to give me
the what it's asking for here so for
example if I just said something like
this I could say something like give me
the length of the number of moons listed
in the status at here or for example I
could say something like um how about I
try saying all right let's try doing
this let's say instead of saying all
here let me say select the length of
hash moons okay so let's say what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to say
give me all planets with them give me
only the total mass for only for those
planets that have more than ten moons so
this is how we would do that kind of
query and I could say you know I could I
could then if i wanted to i could say
pie chart oh that's chart legends like
that so that will then give me a pie
chart of that and so on okay well and we
can we can do all kinds of other
computations like this what's
interesting is the way that we we get to
use kind of symbolic language combined
in as part of the sort of querying
mechanism for this kind of symbolic
representation of a data set okay well
lots and lots of other kinds of things
we can do maybe I should talk now about
how one takes these kinds of internal
compass
tional capabilities and deploys them to
the outside world so for example how
would we sort of deploy an app to the
outside world so let's let's say we make
some trivial thing here let's say we
make a something that just plotz some
makes a plot here okay great and now we
have a little slider to control that
plot now let's say we want to deploy
this to the outside world but what we
can go ahead and say do is to say cloud
deploy this this thing and now we'll get
something which has deployed that
manipulate to our cloud oh come on um
and if I sign in I should be able to see
this some it's a little weird um so this
this will now show me apart from that
weird glitch which I very much don't
understand this is what i get for
running yesterday's version of of our
language um but any case that the
pointer this is a pure web page and i
just took the thing that i created on
the desktop within morphin language and
i deployed it to the cloud so now i've
got this little little cloud app that
does that or for example i could say let
me let me take something like come how
about i do this let's say i want some
let's just say position of the ISS okay
so this should give me position of the
and let's say to make a Geo visible
region of that and let's say let's make
a Geographics of that oops um and now ah
ok so this should show me operators of
the ocean um let's uh let's try doing
this
okay there we go okay so it's in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean um they
track it to another geo projection to
make it to make it prettier but but
let's try and make an app that shows the
position of the ISS so look what I want
to do is I want to say make this delayed
so it's only going to be computed at the
time when um when this is some when I
asked for it and let's say I want to
let's make this a publicly accessible
app and now what I'm going to do is it
will now deploy that to the cloud now
whenever I go to that cloud location it
will oh I forgot to do something here it
will give me um it should be able to say
I want to put it on the web so on to say
exported as for example PNG ok so now i
will have created a little app that
whenever i go to it it will show me that
the current position of the ISS if i
wanted to i could now pick up that app
um see I could I could that that app
should be visible I should let me let me
make it let me do this let me say I'm
going to I'm going to make this app
accessible elsewhere let's do this ok so
now let's say um I go to my phone and I
go and I look at some wool from cloud
app on my phone so you can see this and
some place here should be the thing that
I just deployed hopefully it always
should have deployed it how about I
deployed an actual named thing that way
that way will that way I'll know where
it is um let's call it is s ok so now
now hopefully he will see here umm my
son logged into a different server or
something confusing no there we go
thursday so there's the ISS app that we
just made so i can now go to it on my
phone and I'll get that same result or
if I wanted to I could go and deploy
this app to my
watch and I could go and see we get to
her next level of stack I mean let me
notice that the I just have to tell it
here to UM to make that available on the
watch go um select objects to go on an
Apple watch there we go save that and
now I could now you pull that up thats a
map up on my watch and it will will
compute the same thing so it's okay so
that's some that's a little bit more on
how you can kind of deploy a nap let's
try let's try something where we want to
make come and see if that let's see if
this works again